gloomy the mood around here Parliament
in gridlock cabinet summon this
afternoon to try and clear a path
through now that Boris Johnson looks set
to break his Halloween brexit promise so
what's the solution thumbs up from him a
smile from her but this lot don't have
much to be happy about brexit delayed
the brexit bill paused and no majority
in parliament the Commons leader and
chief went looking for a way out of this
mess pushing for winter warfare it's
Morris Johnson going to be the Christmas
Grinch
I mean well well all these decisions are
for Parliament farm it needs to decide
whether it wants to deliver brexit or
not and then polymer needs to decide
whether it wants to give the people the
chance to decide who's going to leave
our country we expect you to table a
motion for a general election then I
think it's highly likely
I think they've the only way out of this
is for the people to decide who they
want to leave the country
soon after cabinet broke up Boris
Johnson broke cover the way to get this
done the way to get brexit done is I
think to be reasonable with Parliament
and say if they genuinely want more time
to study this excellent deal they can
have it but they have to agree to a
general election on December the 12th
read between the lines Boris Johnson's
admitting that he can't keep that
promise to leave the EU do-or-die on
Halloween so he's going for a christmas
election instead offering labour the
chance to amend and change his brexit
bill in return for them giving him the
election he so craves and if they refuse
he confirmed the Labour Party as brexit
blockers running scared of the public
labour refusing to be bounced by Boris
Johnson we want an election because we
want to take our case the people of this
country but we do not want this country
to be in any danger of crashing out of
the EU without a deal because of all the
damage that will do to jobs services and
trade all over this country
mr. Johnson's named his Christmas
election date but it's not in his gift
he's got to persuade two thirds of
Parliament to go along with him many of
the opposition as well as his own MPs
are reluctant Beth Rigby Sky News
Westminster